scoops you back in now don't crush the
cat who's right behind you Oh
fortunately you're a cat man mm-hmm I
know this I respect you anyhow what's up
reject nation I'm Craig Alba what's your
name good sir
em dog from struggle nation em dog from
struggle nation ECOMOG is another way to
refer to him if you guys haven't seen
his channel he just recently hit 1000
subscribers go over there right now he's
on reactor up-and-coming speaking of
which we're gonna be watching five
creepy dolls moving top five haunted
dolls caught on tape this comes from a
channel called nukes top five dolls
creeped me out
speaking of things that are creepy I
just did a reaction that's going on his
channel struggle nation to the short
film called dead buddy
Dead by Dawn and Evil Dead story you
should go watch the short film there's a
link in the description box if you like
Evil Dead if you like horror shorts this
one really hits the mark that's all I'll
say wow did a reaction should be on
there okay let's watch this other creepy
thing Halloween creepy dolls moving
concave strange expressions
now this next video requires a quick
meta backstory in the early 1970s Mattel
Toys produced a doll called saucy
rotating the doll's arm one actually
caused the bird eyes and even its facial
expression to change youtuber Brian
libecki who collects creepy dolls claims
that he owns a haunted saucy doll brian
says that his doll space changing gears
are completely broken
Mattel asahikawa supposed to be able to
do this and all that you can hear the
train commotion that doesn't work
however Brian claims that late at night
the doll still on its own
[Music]
Oh Oh oh hell no
she why you still thought that there was
doing it Barney what no [ __ ] is
kutzia there's cuts but two cuts the
camera the monitor the doll's face all
right Lucy with no cuts yeah show off
shove all three hours normal speed whoa
[Music]
that is so eerie
[Music]
it's gonna give the finger I hope it
does make let's creep on one do you
think is this a haunted doll moving its
face on its own or is it just a creepy
thing I don't care what it is it needs
to get burned another House Speaker guy
in this video patty from the YouTube
channel G team paranormal is
investigating an entire collection of
supposedly haunted dolls Heather from
the YouTube channel Heather's hauntings
is also filming the investigation as
tips to communicate with the dolls be in
a spirit box but document doing that I
was glad to stay there haunted dolls I'm
pretty much 100% sure now that they are
all haunted for sure I mean we already
know that the big one is we've seen her
move in my office because that song was
playing yeah oh oh that way they won't
forget yes patty says that she plans on
badal was that music though that where'd
that come from been more active both
Patti and Heather capture the incident
on camera I'm not taking her with me
when I move so if any of you are
interested in at all please let me know
because I don't want to keep her but I'd
like her to go to a good home I mean
there's somebody out there who's
interested I don't are you serious
that wasn't one of you should really
just move it's called nipple chills
right now oh no oh my god Heather I got
the cold chills from the top of my head
to my freakin job the poll shows you can
check out the full videos and see all
the things that have you ever caught on
camera over on their YouTube channels
eating paranormal investigators and on
Heather's Channel
Heather's hauntings that's a little head
too much but Kersal money out by post
- a TV is a bit of a strange YouTube
channel a guy named Casey doesn't
standard tech reviews of electronic
gadgets and audio equipment but then
occasionally it will disorder some
random creepy thing from the internet
I'm full review and paranormal
investigation of the object in this case
[Music]
crying is infected and clean the dead
and horrible nightmares of being trapped
in a fire so Casey receipts the dolphin
does a few paranormal tests but he's a
bit disappointment by the results
already so looking but this thing is not
gone once know this in your thoughts now
how does a test number two there was
some kind of activity going on not
enough to say that this is haunted yet
but then he decides to set the doll on
the shelf and record it overnight with
an infrared camera okay caught on tape
it's jelly don't distract us too much it
was it who oh hell no uh-uh
nah nope no one
there's a noise oh that is so creepy
nope I don't wanna see it this sounds
wrong
[Music]
wouldn't have that in house I cry
freakish standing in the end
Casey decides to cut his test short and
just get rid of the doll smart man even
goes so far as to burn the figurine the
ashes and he hired a priest this haunted
doll moving caught on tape or just an
elaborate hoax you decide by the way you
can check out Casey's full possessed
doll video I'm good over on this channel
though watching you no thank you
bruising says that she bought this
creepy doll of an antique fair is all
your humors and all eyes and actually be
enough money to give it to following her
and she didn't streets in the videos
people don't know there's a cat here
looks like I'm scratching to close too
close
mmm the greedy encounter doesn't stop
there later in the video tuna is the
dusting the smell it eyes begin to
follow her again tracking her each side
the side
[Music]
that's a little creepy
what
[Music]
it should be noted that the doll has no
mechanical mechanism to make it either
head follow anyone your River Commission
also be noted that Moodle brews on
YouTube channel is not paranormal in
nature at all
in fact almost all her other videos are
about her pet hamsters so is this a
haunted doll or just some very spooky
coincidental head and eye movements let
me know what you think Provo for other
yeah yeah bro alright YouTube I just
said get ready to abandon music boxes
they're just started playing sorry I'm a
little sick I was trying to rest but you
know after putting this in dull that
kind of show
[Music]
and she said that she called
[Music]
holy holy did you see that hands are
shaking
sorry makes me feel a oh I'm actually
probably going to lock this thing back
up what just happened you can't move
them screw that
wait finally decides to just look better
belong to the doll take it out back in
people to get out of you in the audience
you decide as always thanks for my own
Twitter at nukes top 5 for more random
weirdness and if you'd like to submit or
suggest a video for the top 5 go to
facebook.com slash nukes top 5 and hit
the send message button watch them in
all of my videos alright alright alright
so weirdly number 2 number 1 are the
ones I have the hardest time believe it
or actually something yeah number 2 with
the doll making its little eye movement
and like he did acknowledge the dolls
have nothing mechanical involved in them
but are supposed to make its eyes move
at the same time though I just feel like
think I don't know actually I guess I
just don't want to believe it everybody
yeah don't want to believe it like that
could be anything down malfunction or
yeah every middle oh there's kind of
weird yeah no you're moving its eyes are
following yeah it is creepy but I feel
like that could be I don't know it just
could be something else
just since the music behind it also kind
of amplified it but sure sure number one
choice another could have a doctor a
little too easily it's like he was over
selling it yeah I mean these things have
like weird haunted legends to it so the
slightest weird thing that occurs they
think that it could be something yeah
I'll give it to them even the ones that
I don't believe in the moment I still
find them very creepy yeah they're
definitely creepy when you see it yes so
even if I have that moment later of I
don't believe it I still
expected for how creepy it actually is
fair enough fair enough but the first
three that they showed us I thought were
pretty freakin whoo-hoo I mean the first
guy the number five pick there was a lot
of cuts that happened I mean like we
were pointing out but to its credit I
mean there's like that time-lapse video
we need to get our hands about
time-lapse yeah drew pull some strings
get that time-lapse video for us call my
contacts
thank you sure drew knows a lot more
people than you believe he just hit two
thousand subscribers on YouTube just
right now he's just right now that's
what I'm talking about that first one
though I I actually thought it was
really creepy when they cuts back and
then that one eyes closed yeah dude was
creepy
it was and then the time-lapse with the
eyes moving I could buy it I could
believe it I feel like that I don't know
I don't know if this really is really
subtle and I feel like they sped it up
so much that maybe it's like natural
movement and they made it you look I
don't know if there's one that I would
believe the one that really creeped me
out was the tech one where it had like
that black and white ordeal to it that's
all the ones I found scary move yeah
because it was like looking right at the
camera yeah like now you is being
watched I feel like that's one that that
will be easily faked cuz you could you
know hook some fishing line up to it and
I could pull it right but I don't want
to like try to debunk everything cuz you
don't know you don't know like it was
creepy enough for me to believe that
could actually happen I don't know how
would you have it in the house but
nothing he burned it smart man
shoutout to you because the same thing I
would do what a lot of these guys do is
they put down this like hidden camera
hmm hidden camera and then let it they
let it just record it when they're not
around and there's a happen when they're
not around
I really admire the one with the family
when they're like in the backyard port
yeah yeah I'm gonna you know I'm just
gonna say I believe it I'm just gonna go
up there and go I believe it only
because they seem to have really work
their asses off on selling it even if it
is fake you know but it's like them
selling it I didn't buy them selling it
like oh my god did the head just move is
like okay I didn't buy it
I don't know that the actor wasn't it
wasn't there for me now I could be wrong
I could be wrong I don't want this guy
this discredited but it's like oh my god
did you see that no was that you know oh
my god what's this what's that like
I bought it dude that's how white people
behave I mean but I've met white people
that don't behave like that though like
but not all white people are the same
geez I mean listen according to
Wikipedia they are so I believe I don't
know what do I believe in the court in
the movies that I've seen they all do
the same stuff they investigating that
first movies aren't accurate I'm saying
and the cliche in horror movies are true
the white guy always dies first yeah
because he goes and visca what is that
crazy no yo what are you who are you why
are you oh no no the happens every
single time happens I don't know I don't
know I mean you gotta admit though the
way shot that was pretty well done it no
it was it was I'll give it that
I'll give it that like the thing that
the cheddar wind chimes over there
moving the cameras moving left to right
I mean the time is coincidental as part
of it they trying to settle it in the
package you know so I'm like okay it's
all part of it no I think it what makes
it a little too elaborate is with the
wind chimes actually because I'm like
now you're do too many horror movies
yeah because the head moving thing was
good enough on its own because it was
subtle then it was a lot then it's like
what the hell I'll give that one credit
just because the music I was playing
I'll make that a ringtone and everything
like I don't know what the doll was
saying supposedly but that music was was
fire so have you ever had a creepy doll
hell no no I don't know no really I
wouldn't do that
mm-hmm if I have any kind of action
figure with doll and it moves it's
getting destroyed would you ever get
like a female doll and then like a male
one and then my take the clothes off of
them and then have them like make love
to me it's too much work I don't want
the simple I can just watch movies for
that I'm just gonna make the whole scene
you know how much time and effort that
takes that's way too much time sure I
don't want to sit there and plant whole
scene now I got to write and direct and
produce I don't want to on top of that
back in the day told VHS tape think you
put them in over thinking your fantasy
that would take five minutes
listen the fantasies you had that's a
lot of work you you don't just take the
clothes you got to set the scene you had
a mixed age and that's true so there's a
lot of work that goes in I spent three
months creating character background the
whole backstory and everything I just
want to have the scene see the scene in
Anessa
you know this is true fantasy I had when
I was a little kid I watch this movie
called Indian in the cupboard cupboard
and there's a copper yet a little
Delinda yep yeah and actually just here
the time with the white kid yeah yeah if
you guys haven't seen it what happens is
you put a toy in there and then you when
you uh do the lock thing comes out and
the toy comes to life and I used to
imagine me shrinking down putting a
Barbie in this cupboard and then you
know bringing this Barbie to life and
then making love to it that's way better
fancy than just get the two dollars and
the clothes and all that but that's
actually legit thank you that that's
that's that's good that's way more
leverage than the ones I had back in the
day you see the creepiness of that does
not come from the dolls themselves the
creepiness comes from the little boy
well fair enough fair enough
all right guys well this was fun you can
subscribe to the real rejects subscribe
to nooks top 5 YouTube channel there's a
lot of top 5 horror related yeah yeah
there's one of the most insisted this
was well produced a well executed the
narration there and voiceover yeah head
over do it and each one is engaging yeah
even if we don't believe it it's still
very engaging yeah yeah yeah
check out struggle nation their short
film telling you guys it's well worth it
if you like horror it's violent giving
you a heads up there a little bit and
yeah we'll catch you guys soon thanks
for being here thanks for inviting me
you're welcome let's put you in the
cupboard
I'm already loved even better job is
done